[Music]
community health workers play an
important role for the health of women
and their families often they're the
connection to the health care system and
they educate women about the importance
of interventions like vaccines and
family planning they also provide
important healthcare through models like
integrated community case management
that address nutrition malaria diarrhea
and pneumonia now let me tell you a
story about a health care worker in
Ghana that we recently met
she works in a clinic in a small village
in the whole region of Ghana which is
approximately three hours north of the
capital in her clinic there is no
electricity there's no running water now
these two elements are critical to
ensure safe and effective use of
medicines for example vaccines need to
be stored at a specific temperature to
maintain their effectiveness and
therefore they are stored in fridges
which are powered by electricity instead
of storing the vaccines in her clinic
the healthcare worker travels one hour
each way on the bus to get fresh
vaccines and transport them for the day
in a cooler
she then works all day at the clinic
administering these vaccines and seeing
mothers children and babies without the
dedication of health care workers like
this one in Ghana it's very likely that
communities of children would not have
the opportunity to be vaccinated as a
global company you'd expect that we'd
have a great passion for innovating to
discover new vaccines and we do that but
you might not expect is that we're also
truly passionate about innovating on our
existing vaccines both in the vaccine
vial and in the packaging they arrive in
we do this based on learnings about the
constraints that face the people we are
trying so very hard to reach so what
does innovation look like well I've
brought a vial to show you this tiny
vial is an incredible testament to
scientific innovation until 2017 it
provided one dose to vaccinate one child
but now this vial provides four doses so
we can vaccinate four children by
combining multiple doses into one vial
we've reduced the storage space and the
requirements innovations like this will
help make it easier to get vaccines to
children everywhere here is a startling
fact sub-saharan Africa bears nearly 25%
of the disease burden in the whole world
and yet they only have 3% of global
health care workers so one of the things
we feel is really critical is ensuring
that health care workers are trained to
administer vaccines for example 2017 was
the first year that Pfizer's new
multi-dose vial became available in Gavi
countries in order to ensure the health
care workers were appropriately trained
we partnered with a MP and the World
Health Organization to develop a
pneumococcal conjugate refresher course
along with the training program on our
multi-dose vial in partnership with
w-h-o and our implementing partner a MP
we developed a train-the-trainer model
for our new multi dose vial the
train-the-trainer model allows country
ownership by starting with a small group
of healthcare workers who then become
master trainers then in turn they train
the next level of healthcare workers
until the training reaches the most
remote villages the materials are all
engaging and easy to understand the
training finishes with a required
knowledge test we have to make sure that
vaccines get to those who need them the
most I've often said that our job
doesn't end when we make a vaccine and
ship it to a distribution center what
good is a vaccine if it isn't reaching
the people who need it the most
or if the healthcare workers aren't able
to administer a new version of our
vaccine like our multi-dose vial so when
our new multi dose vial became available
in Gavi countries in 2017 we trained
27,000 healthcare workers across 15
countries and this year we expanded the
program to an additional nine countries
with the goal of reaching another 17,000
healthcare workers by the end of the
year I firmly believe that strengthening
global partnerships between public and
private stakeholders
is essential to providing a brighter and
healthier future for all it's why I'm so
excited to see all the focus and
commitment around sustainable
development goal number three good
health and well-being one of the most
impressive private public partnerships
working toward that goal is being
spearheaded by Gavi The Vaccines
Alliance now Pfizer is very proud to be
a part of this effort which is working
to speed up access to life-saving
vaccines which are delivered by the
teams from UNICEF and local ministries
of health care working on the ground
working with Gavi we advisor have been
supplying millions of doses of our
vaccines to help protect the world's
most vulnerable children
this partnership opens the door to good
health for more children helping to
prevent disease especially in
communities where health care systems
are still developing
[Music]